which brings us to the the heroism of
sarah fuller now sarah fuller seems like
an amazing athlete okay she's a way
better athlete than i will ever be
obviously right she was the
soccer goalkeeper for vanderbilt
university and
she played in the uh she played in the
power five
over the weekend and she was named the
special teams player of the week and she
kicked a squib kick to start off the
second half of saturday's game against
missouri
vanderbilt lost the game 41-0
so i'm not sure like that's nice
okay i'm not sure why that is like a
major achievement for women it seems
like
major achievements for women would
generally be like a major achievement
for a man but a woman did it
it wouldn't be like she did a thing that
a man did but not as well as a man and
therefore it's a major achievement for a
woman to do a thing that a man could do
but not nearly as well as a man would do
it
like that that's not a major achievement
right a major she's a she's
an amazing athlete she's an amazing
women's soccer star
okay that is not the same as being like
amazing on the men's team in football
that's not
the same thing and it's not a major
achievement for a woman to do something
that a man could do in a men's game
and not do it like amazingly well so she
but affirmative action applies when it
comes to the way the media cover these
things
the sec announced her as the special
teams player of the week
fuller made history she became the first
woman ever to officially take the field
during a football game in a major
conference football game now she didn't
actually like take a tackle it wasn't
like jj watt like went right at her
right and tackled her because that would
be incredibly dangerous but the
announcement says
she took the opening kickoff of the
second half against the tigers as her
perfectly executed kick sailed 30 yards
and was down at the missouri 35-yard
line
okay um so i
um so
30 yards
i mean better than i could do i mean i'm
just gonna keep saying that because
that's where twitter goes like well
she's better
yes granted she can kick the ball
further than i can i also
did not aspire to play on the vanderbilt
football team
nor do i have the physical capacity to
do so let's just show
film of this kick the greatest kick
apparently of all time like in all of
history
here she was kicking off the second half
for vanderbilt university and this was
the great historic moment for which she
won the special teams
player of the week award
[Applause]
um kick down at the 35 yard that did not
tail
that was not um thanksgiving so it's a
squib
what a day right as a squid kick what a
day in college football
what a day she kicked a ball
no one is anywhere within a thousand
yards of her
she kicked it maybe 25 yards and then it
bounced like another five
and um what a day huge huge
step for win no see i think big steps
for women are like you know i'm just
gonna say this
my wife does more for women and for
women's empowerment than sarah fuller
kicking a ball on a men's football team
with no chance of actually playing i
mean i'm sorry but like kicking a ball
20 yards and having no chance of being
tackled is not exactly like what we mean
when we think of people
playing football so much i mean like
that's that's nice she's a soccer player
she's a great
why is it not enough for her to just be
a great soccer player i don't understand
okay my wife
who is a doctor and has three children
that seems like more of a
groundbreaking thing for women to do is
to be a doctor
right because women can be just as great
as men and being a doctor but
to treat this like this was like an
amazing performance is
kind of incredible okay the the other
person
who won the uh who won
the special teams player of the week was
kedarius tony
um and i just um i want to look up what
he actually
did last week okay so he actually scored
on a punt return
okay so that seems like more important
than not kicking a football all that
well in a game that you lose 41-0
so he earned special teams player of the
week co-special teams player of the week
for the sec
he returned to punt 50 yards which ended
up being the
touchdown that gave the gators a 14 10
edge at halftime
he also scored a passing rushing
receiving and punch punt return
touchdown in a career that was the first
punt return touchdown
since in 85 yarder in 2018 for the
florida gators
um on the year he has 45 receptions for
541 yards and seven touchdowns
and it's slightly more impressive i
think than kicking a ball like 20 yards
and having no chance of being tackled
but again people are well but yes but
it's groundbreaking for a woman okay if
you have to add for a woman it's not
groundbreaking
seriously because you're demonstrating
that the woman is not playing on the
same level as the men
if you have to have that was a great
performance for a woman
it would have to be a great performance
for a man in a man's sport for it to be
truly groundbreaking okay but that's not
where the the absurdity stops so
apparently
sarah fuller i'm not kidding you gave a
halftime speech
to the team according to joe kinsey at
outkick
hey espn reporter courtney cronin jumped
on a zoom call to chat with fuller about
her time
on the vanity football team and that's
when we learned that fuller was given
the floor to address her fellow football
players
if i'm gonna be honest i was a little
pissed off at how quiet everybody was on
the sideline fuller told cronin
we made a first down and i was the only
one sure and i was like what the heck
what's going on
and i tried to get them pumped up and i
was like you guys need to start cheering
your team on
my main thing was during the sec
tournament my entire team was cheering
the entire time
it didn't matter if we were in the
locker room or if they were on the
sidelines i think that's what won it for
us everyone was cheering non-stop
i just went in there and i said exactly
what i was thinking i was like we need
to be cheering each other on this is how
you win games this is how you get better
by calling each other out for stuff and
i'm gonna call
you guys out we need to be supporting
one another if we get a first down if an
interception happens it's our fault we
need to be lifting each other up that's
what a team is about i think this team
has struggled and that's been part of it
okay she's been part of the team
for 32 seconds and she kicked a squib
kick okay first of all
it is not a perfectly executed squib
kick okay i just you don't have to be a
football expert to understand when a
squib kick is used a squib kick is used
at the end usually of the first half
when you're just trying to run out the
clock and you don't want to see somebody
run it back
you never use a squip kick when you are
down one million points at the beginning
of the second half
and give fuel position to the other team
35-yard line anyway
okay but she's been on the team for like
half a second and she's lecturing
all the male players about what a winner
she is in a completely different sport
with women
that is not effective i mean can you can
you imagine the temerity of that
seriously like just the absolute goal of
that to walk into the men's football
team
these guys by the way are getting
crushed out there right not just like
they're losing they're getting
physically mauled out there because
that's what football is
these guys are going out there and
getting stomped on yeah linebackers who
are getting bruised up
and you get this woman walking in the
front door she squib kicks at 20 yards
and she's like
i think that you guys are losers i think
and you know what i'm gonna lecture you
about how to be winners and the way
that we can be winners is by cheering
each other on guys we're gonna cheer
like there's no tomorrow we're gonna
cheer and that's gonna bring
the entire team together female
empowerment
she says i hope i gained their respect
it wasn't dill intentioned at all i just
want this team to succeed
and do well so uh uh
okay so again a few notes one jason
whitlock has noted
that um that she was practicing all week
long she didn't try a field goal because
the team didn't score the entire game
but her longest field goal i believe she
says is 38 yards
which is great for any
person who is not a male football player
in an sec team right if you're in the
power five
you got to be able to get more in a
38-yard field goal any in any case
the vanderbilt coach came out and said
that the kick went exactly where it was
supposed to and also i didn't want to
over coach her
i don't think there was a chance of that
i don't think it was like if you
overcoached her she was going to squib
kick at 15 yards
here's the coach who by the way now has
no job he was fired because his team
stinks
we tried to go with the most naturals
the the most natural kicks
like in her arsenal um tried not to
you know you know over coach her but let
her you know
do and understand you know uh
what what felt comfortable to her and
that's really what we went with
uh man and i thought she punched it
exactly where she needed to punch it
um falls down 35 yard line let's go um
so that was normally you don't actually
build
like an entire play calling situation
around a kicker who only kicks the ball
about 25 yards like that's that's
normally not what you
do so can we stop pretending that this
is like some great historic breakthrough
for women
women are not going to be populating the
power 5 anytime soon
wake me when a woman is playing
quarterback for a power five team or a
linebacker or wide receiver or
cornerback
or anything that is not a kicker who if
they were a dude would not be
on the team obviously also i just got to
point this out again the differences
between men and women are very real and
this actually underscores that there are
differences between men and women
because if there were no differences
then she would not be on the team
obviously nor would she win sec
co-player of the week with a guy who ran
back a 50-yard punt return
for university of florida anyway the the
halftime speech really gets me it really
does because again it again betrays the
difference between
men and women differences that are very
real okay one of those differences
is how men talk in the locker room
versus how women talk
in the locker room so women when it
comes to halftime speeches
apparently according to the book top dog
which is a an excellent book by poe
bronson and ashley merriman
about the science of competition talks
about how men and women are motivated by
different things right because men and
women are not
exactly the same i know this is very
controversial stuff because
again we're supposed to simultaneously
believe that men and women are exactly
the same but also they are not exactly
the same so it's historic when a woman
plays in a man's game
so in any case they are not motivated by
the same thing so she's on the sideline
like why aren't you guys cheering for
each other i want more solidarity i want
more team spirit
none of that motivates dudes none of
that motivates dudes that is not how
dudes get motivated
dudes get motivated by al pacino in any
given sunday screaming in people's faces
and telling them that they're acting
like pansies so get out there and prove
that you're not a pansy
women are motivated by solidarity
they're motivated by compassion
these are things okay so you know who
says this not me
because if i say it then it's very bad
anson dorans who is the unc
women's soccer coach right one of the
great women's soccer coaches of all time
he coached the men's
team at unc university of north carolina
and then coached the women's team and
here is what he said
quote the single is from top dog the
single best example of how dorians
coaches women
is in his halftime speech when he
coached men dorian's best ever half-time
speech was when he got so mad he kicked
a trash can through a window
i drove that sucker through a window and
i stormed out he recalled in the man
watching let me tell you something about
human evolution that spoke volumes to
the men in the room in the second half
everything changed
all of a sudden we had great energy
tactics shape and the game totally
turned around
some men he feels need shock to wake
them up top men are so used to
competition that even being on the
losing end at halftime is not shock
enough
but he would never treat women that way
as doran's said
quote if they've played poorly still
comes swarming in like a cage tiger but
because these are women they can sense
immediately that you're upset
the critical thing is tone you turn to
face them and you calmly say well what
do you think
now you can hear a course of
self-flagellation as every woman in the
room is taking full responsibility for
the disaster taking place
i haven't criticized anyone i don't need
to because they're their own worst
critics
and now when the half-time talk ends
they're willing to die for you because
all you've done
is support them okay so again
i i love that she comes in she's like
i'm gonna turn this male team around by
lecturing them about togetherness and
all the guys like
what is this now what is it but men and
women exactly the same
in every possible way prove that they're
exactly the same
is that we put a woman on the field and
celebrated her and had
today's show interviews with her and
talked about how historic it was
when she kicked a ball not all that far
in a game that her team lost by 41
points
so well done everybody gender ideology
making zero sense every single day
every single day facts don't care about
your feelings and it's a fact that the
ben shapiro show is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content